there are great many changes but there
we are
age is rarely kind to anyone
nothing welcome to about it one just has
to get on with it I had no doubts that
Olivia could do it but she's amazing to
watch and the new cast didn't bother me
it was how to make the new cast feel
like it was the same show I just wanted
to feel it was seamless and I think it
does I was such a fan of series 1 & 2
the writing is beautiful I was thrilled
to see that it carried on being just as
good as I'd hoped
where does government got to step in
you're kind of witnessing them in it
changing Britain so it it becomes quite
turbulent the challenges for both of
them come from outside the marriage in
this season any track from this family
is met with the healthy doses and then
despite good-natured teasing that's a
lot of rivalry she really loved her
sister profoundly and I think they
regretted there was enough of that
closeness also in season 3 mother-son
relationship is extraordinary and I see
for who and what I am no do I have a
voice here is a man who in order for his
life to take meaning and to take
importance his mother has to die that is
a huge monumental philosophical thing
the crown rearranges everything within
that family it rearranges precedents
principles and priorities and they can't
be who they might want to be or indeed
who they're best suited to be it's
basically about a family that's why we
relate to it but then in extraordinary
circumstances and yet also having very
ordinary reactions to
we have to be in full view all the time
so what's the answer
ritual and mystery because it keeps us
hidden while still in plain sight the
smoke and the mirrors the mystery and
the protocol it's not there to keep us
apart it is there to keep us alive